hier soir danse et que du coup bernard
montiel nous faisait des révélations sur
la fameuse interview qu'il avait donnée
à jean marc morandini dans laquelle il
avait défoncé toutes les personnalités
de tf1 s'était à l'époque ce qui
ad'ailleurs avait coûté sa place c'est
une séquence j'avais adoré
vraiment il nous a parlé avec le coeur
et ça fait des années que cette
interview était fait il avait été viré
de tf1 news arrate enquête tout ça
c'était comme un 18 trous ya des raisons
et pourtant les petites anecdotes de
bernard hier ont eu de grandes
conséquences
et oui on va en parler dans un instant
d'abord si vous n'étiez pas là hier
regardez ce qu'il avait dit et bien
après bernard sera avec nous pour nous
raconter des conséquences qu'il ya eu
suite à ces révélations
apparemment tf1 est toujours sur ses
côtes
regardez c'est sur tf1 dont vous aviez
dézinguer tout vos camarades
ouais qu'est ce qui s'est passé racontez
moi comment ça s'est passé pour me
sortir un peu de l'image de vidéos gars
qui étaient quand même très légère et
proposer une émission sur le cinéma
parce que j'aime ça monde était d'accord
sauf que on l'a donné à quelqu'un
d'autre
sauf que là du coup je me dis attend
alors là ils m'ont pris pour un con je
veux leur filer plein la gueule
alors moi kappeler jean marc morandini
qu'à l'époque et rmc jeudi jean-marc tu
vas très content si tu me rend fou et
surtout tu me poses des questions que tu
veux n'aie pas peur donc la vo pose des
questions que pensez-vous d'arthur et là
vous lui dites pas à b to b arthur
gélibert tueur on peut pas trop le
critiquer parce que il va pleurer tout
de suite là au septième et donc
effectivement j'avais c'est qu'ils
savaient pas lire un prompteur et tous
les journaux l'ont repris évidemment et
au monde ravi de taper sur tf1 arthur
cas pas plus pour te mettre un petit
coup de pression jamais personne
personne à part si je n'avais aucun
procès parce que j'ai dit des choses
terribles
alors bernard montiel est avec nous et
vous allez voir que cette histoire a
encore fait couler beaucoup d'encre
après dix huit ans après cette histoire
frappe encore bien sûr bernard montiel
merci d'être là c'est un bernard montiel
meurtri qui nous rejoint ce soir sachez
le c'est un bernard montiel qui attrapé
un coup de soleil un coup d' amour coup
de jeune les révélations de bernard
montiel ont eu de grosses de grandes
conséquences j'aurai tout commence il ya
quelques semaines
fanny allemand une sculpteuse qui
travaillent et pour beaucoup
d'associations décide de faire un clip
pour sos inceste et ça appelle à
plusieurs personnalités dont bernard
montiel on regarde un extrait de ce pipe
et on vous raconte l'histoire juste
après
histoire commence comme ça je peux vous
dire que l'histoire qu'on va vous
raconter la folle fait froid dans le dos
regarde c'est fou inscrit quelques
lettres de mon prénom j'ai beau estrie
de l'udc
à peine rentré dans la pénombre il
inscrit toujours pas de réponse
david dans sa course sans vie avaient ce
mal qui meurent en silence crise et
pourtant voilà on y voit notre playboy
bernard montiel qui la voient là et
c'est un clip importants resteraient sur
scène et c'est une association
importante juste on n'en pas deux
petites secondes doigt sur l'essence est
bernard brisset ce sos inceste et
violences sexuelles c'est pour protéger
les enfants exactement kim de violences
sexuelles y en a beaucoup c'est
l'inceste le texte est très fort et
disent beaucoup de choses
j'étais très touchée quand on m'a
contacté fanny allemand cette jeune
fille que je ne connaissais pas m'a
contacté très gentiment grâce à l'acteur
antoine coince à lorient et à d'acteurs
de dante qui joue yahia bruno solo
thierry beccaro jean claude dreyfus
bernard montiel dwyer ferriol il ya
également ondoyer qui a participé à ce
clip et ce matin elle m'appelle alors on
va voir ce qui s'y est essayé parce que
regarder ce qui se passe ce matin
ce matin peu avant 9 heures ouais vous
recevez un coup de fil oui oui alors là
j'ai été très surpris ses fans allemands
et elle me dit bon bernard je suis tout
à fait je vous dirai ce que fanni il
avait proposé le clip à tf1 pour qui
l'accusatrice a fait quinze jours qu'ils
étaient en négociation avec tf1 pour
diffuser ce clip ce qui est normal et
légitime
ils étaient pas contre visiblement il
est suite à ce que j'ai dit sans doute y
r je ne sais pas en tout cas
fanny allemand m'appelle ce matin amélie
bernard gros problème vous savez que je
vous soutiens etc
mais ils montrent qu'ils mendient qui ne
diffuseront jamais ce clip
voilà il attendait la réponse depuis
quinze jours donc comme ce matin par
hasard on lui a dit on diffusera jamais
ce clip est d'autant plus qu'il ya pas
mal d'acteurs dedans qui ne nous
plaisent pas il nous conviennent pas
alors moi première action tellement
désolé parce que c'est un truc
humanitaire enfin c'est pour les enfants
à bien sûr très choquée franchement
j'étais pas comme étant aussi sonné je
suis toujours pas content c'est choquant
c'est inadmissible et choquant bon
maintenant il n'était pas obligé non
plus de le diffuser ça peut être aussi
service public qu'on va aller voir
d'ailleurs par la suite
alors moi j'ai dit bien retirer moi si
le problème vient de moi pas pour à ce
que j'ai dit hier
ensuite j'ai été gêné j'ai déjà vu août
j'ai dit madame je suis désolé
enlevez-moi de l'image à me dis jamais
vous avez été le premier à accepter
jamais je le ferai jamais bon alors
voilà on est là c'est très décevant
j'espère que c'est pas lié à ce que j'ai
dit hier cette histoire d'hier que j'ai
raconté qu est strictement vrai que je
maintiens elle date tout de même de 10 à
18 ans comme ça va il ya eu trois
directions entre temps donc ceux qui
sont actuellement au pouvoir à tf1 ne
sont pas mêlés à mon histoire alors elle
vous démissionnez pallier aux messages
ce qu'elle a dû tf1 ce n'est pas lié au
message seuil aux acteurs qui figure
dans le clip ça ainsi nous ne
diffuserons pas ce pub sur les antennes
du groupe tf1
c'est incroyable je vous le dis qu'est
ce que vous en pensez quoi sinon c'est
obligatoire c'est obligatoirement a bien
su à la tombée la tombe et ça veut dire
sur 14 n'a pas pas de chercher à jeter
sur les réseaux sociaux dit tout ce que
vous en pensez bernard poussot joue
centriste non sincèrement d'abord je
suis très gêné parce que c'était pas mon
intention c'est une très belle oeuvre
je suis très gêné de cette histoire et
je lui avais dit retirer mon enfant ça
me gêne beaucoup d'en parler je me sens
coupable parfait non mais non bernard
lama toi mais non mon bernatoire si
c'est pour les enfants les enfants
victimes d'inceste c'est horrible enfin
je veux dire me mêler passage lors j'ai
dit on retire et moi je m'en fous de
bernard et amour tu sais que tu sais que
tu est extrêmement sensible aux cherry
et je te lis tu as rien à voir là dedans
tout à fait ton boulot si on te demander
au contraire d'accepter et de prêter de
ta personnalité pour une association qui
tient à coeur et c'est très très
important plus tous ces problèmes
c'était donc vraiment le cas d'armand on
a fait ça c'est une belle action et 6 à
cause de moi je suis effondré quoi
franchement c'est bon ça que j'ai voulu
venir vous le dira juste soir
mais je suis effondré bernard si c'est
ça vraiment je te le dis mon bernard tu
sais comme je t'aime et comme tu es mon
ami depuis des années c'est ridicule de
leur part toi tu n'as rien à te
reprocher c'est pas avant syrte a juste
accepté de défendre une association
je pense à le croire que je peux pas le
croire que sa cause de sa très fin quand
même cédé et s'est enfui sans important
mais moi je vais moi je vais dire
quelque chose de servette face est la
réponse que ce soit toi au patois
répondre on va pas aider une association
parce qu'il ya des personnalités qui
supposerait qu'on n'aime pas sur la fin
une bêtise c'est vrai qu'à des acteurs
de france 3 aussi à l'égard de chaînes
sur ce qu'on s'en tape là c'est le
message est dix fois plus important bien
sûr les guerres de chaîne france 3 qu'il
a des acteurs de france 3 nous on adore
les un accord plus belle la vie moi
j'adore plus belle la vie je dis la
vérité en face de nous je vais tous les
soirs que j'adore plus belle la vie
scènes de ménage adore scènes de ménage
et voilà qu'en soutien à tous les coups
c'est un super pote ses auteurs aussi
des sur tf1 déjà s'épanouit n'empêche
pas de faire de la promo quand zidane
fait des clips pour son instruction il
footballeurs de tous les clubs etc
il n'y a plus de club il ya plus rien
plus je suis très choqué et j'avoue que
je me sens coupable et je lui dis
enlevez-moi enlevez moi elle m'a dit
jamais je remercie fanny allemand de
mesut özil bravo fanni mais non mais
l'intéressé pour les enfants je veux
dire c'est ce clip et donc du coup il
était en négo depuis quinze jours la
balayer peut-être mais on va voir avec
nos amis de canal + canal notamment mon
ami gérald brice viret et maxime saada
mes deux amis les deux patrons du groupe
et prend capitaux d'autres présidents de
ces huit on va voir avec eux si on peut
les diffuser déjà sur nos antennes bien
sûr des bénévoles je le rappelle
évidemment dans le clip bien sûr
chanteur et bravo à finalement raymond
qui se trouve que ce que tu as dit c'est
bien d'eux parce que y'a quelqu'un de
chez france 3 ou dance is ou de chez
paquet de tf1
ce constat la journée leur slogan c'est
partageons des émotions vivons ensemble
avec vous les français ont fait de la
télé pour vous c'est le côté pourri que
j'aime pas de ce métier là de ce métier
de ceux d'autres de ce truc que je vois
en télé parce que tu m'as mis dans cette
aventure là c'est ce côté pourri parce
qu'on fait un clip tout le monde est
venu tout le monde s'est déplacé c'est
pour une cause qui est noble et parce
que les mecs ont visionné dia j'aime pas
ça galles allez hop on vire le clip oem
et les enfants et l'inceste on s'en fout
on vire le crime j'aime pas ça gueule
c'est ce côté là dans ce métier que je
déteste je me ferais jamais juste parce
que tu as dit on en a rigolé hier ça
fait 18 ans en faisant rigoler
et pour rigoler détendez vous rien d les
mecs vous est tout le temps là d'où on
fait de la télé pour vous le confinement
s'est tapé des films de merde vous avez
fait des rediff parce que vous vouliez
pas perdre de l'argent mais c'est vrai
moi moi elle m'a saoulé la télé pour le
confinement mon saoul et ils vivre
ensemble mais moi ça m'a soudain raison
vivre ensemble on est avec vous le
public le public on s'est tapé quatre
fois la grande vadrouille quatre pôles
corio arrêté de me prendre
même si j'adore lui dit même si j'adore
louis de funès donc ce qu'ils font si
c'est ça bernard
c'est vraiment un hasard parce que hier
comme toys 'r' pense que c'est ça parle
si c'est vraiment ça c'est petit la
cause elle est beaucoup plus importante
que n'importe quelle guerre n'importe
quel propos qui auraient été tenus enfin
voilà et en l'occurrence si c'est
vraiment cette histoire là en plus toi
ben la première chose que tu dis c'est
en les enlever - voilà ce genre date à
une réaction à la fois été les premiers
à dire ok était le premier à dire
enlever moi donc tu as vraiment pas à
tant vouloir du tout et effectivement
cette cause elle est plus importante que
tout et je n'ose imaginer que ça ça fait
bizarre de presse est un incident
bernard enquête catus et compte soutient
à fond ne sois pas triste moshiri on va
voir ce qu'on peut faire et les antennes
du groupe à l'afp
gentil je vais appeler également mes
amis parce que ces nouvelles ont fait
des visions dont takis candilis il
attendra et delphine ernotte et voilà
qu'ils sont formidables et on va essayer
d'appeler et je vais bien sûr appelé mes
amis dames 6 nicolas de tavernot et
thomas valentin pour voir s'ils veulent
bien là oui c'est pour les enfants
victimes de violence pas priver les
enfants
voilà je pense qu'ils doivent ils
doivent déjà avoir le message et on va
voir aussi avec les antennes du groupe
bien sûr oui c'est vraiment la core
division déjà pour voir avec eux mêmes
le groupe nrj avec qui on a de très bons
rapports
c'est très gentil à vous passer très
important ce sont ses enfants
extrêmement malheureux victime d'inceste
alors c'est vrai que c'est très dur
parfois d'en parler à la télévision mais
j'étais extrêmement sensibilisé à cette
cause et et je regrette cette réaction
qui est vraiment pas bien
mais ben bernanke en tout cas sachez que
c'est pas de ta faute et comptait mec
t'as fais juste ton boulot et justement
toi tu as fait tu as fait ça pour la
bonne cause et que ça te retombe sur le
coin de la gueule c'est inadmissible
mais toi tu as fait ce qu'il fallait et
a eu la bonne réaction